welcome back to cbs mornings the
pressure to bring britney griner back to
the u.s is growing stronger after she
was sentenced to prison yesterday in
russia the wnba star was found guilty of
smuggling cannabis oil this morning
secretary of state anthony blinken and
russia's foreign minister said the two
countries will discuss a potential
prisoner exchange nancy cordes has more
reaction to the sentencing
we're inspired every day by bg's
strength in a show of support brittany
griner's teammates from the phoenix
mercury locked arms last night with
players from the connecticut sun holding
a moment of silence before their game i
had no intent
to break any russian laws it came after
the 31 year old griner appeared in a
russian courtroom thursday and was
sentenced to nine years in a penal
colony
i want to apologize to my teammates
my club genka
the fans and the city of ecat
my mistake that i made and the
embarrassment that i brought on to them
she was charged with drug smuggling
after having less than a gram of
cannabis oil in her luggage when she
arrived in russia in february she
shouldn't have been on trial she's
wrongfully detained president biden
called the sentence unacceptable and
vowed to work to bring her home
but russia still has not accepted a u.s
proposed prisoner swap put forth weeks
ago
moscow said they wanted to wait for the
trial to end before negotiating now that
she's convicted it's an opportunity for
our state department and her back
channels to get actually get something
done the u.s proposal reportedly
involved russia releasing reiner and
another detained american paul whalen in
exchange for the u.s giving up convicted
russian arms dealer victor boot do you
think the russians would ever accept a
prisoner swap that wasn't one for one or
two for two two of our prisoners for two
of theirs that's a better question for
the russians what i can tell you is that
we put forth a serious proposal we urge
them to accept it
the white house says that president
biden himself is involved in the efforts
to bring griner home just last month she
sent a letter to the president begging
for his help and saying that she is
terrified michelle that she will never
make it out of russia
wow nancy cordes at the white house
thank you
now that brittany has been sentenced
hopefully the conversation can ramp up
about a prisoner exchange
because she needs to be home there was
also a conversation yesterday about you
know sports guys you are the fact that
she's got to go to russia to earn
additional money because she's not
making
what she should be making in the wnba
she was over there because she needed
more money there's a larger conversation
about the pay of the wnba they increase
that so they don't have to go overseas
women's soccer got it yeah
need to see the equalization that's
right for equity
yeah good point good point david